mal schauen ob mir das jetzt irgendwas
gebracht hat ich bin so freuen und
herzlich willkommen zu einem spiel ich
habe mir gedacht ich spiele heute mal
das spiel springen ninja und zwar ihr
seht schon mein score science das ist
auch gleichzeitig mein highscore bevor
ich jetzt gleich anfangen zu zocken ich
nehme zur zeit das erste mal wieder mit
nach elgato auf und ich habe derzeit das
problem dass das ganze so ein bisschen
asynchron ist natürlich hat die erste
mal so eine verzögerung aber ich nehme
es halt mit dem ipad auf das ist überall
gator am pc angeschlossen und ich habe
zwar ton und alles asynchronen pc das
stört mich auch gar nicht weil ich die
datei dann quasi ihren premiere einfach
so ein bisschen verschieben kann
allerdings habe ich halt auf dem ipad
beim zocken erstmal keinen turm
beziehungsweise nur den ton der auf den
pcs drei sekunden später das heißt man
alle gibt's da draußen die sich
irgendwie mit pcb auskennen und zwei das
problem heute ist ihr seht schon meine
rechte beleuchtung da ist so ein
bisschen to face mäßig der accumer
softbox ist alle unterlegt gerade auf
und ich muss jetzt noch ein video
schnell auf nämlich auch wieder morgens
uni musste ich meinen bei solchen
spielen wie jetzt gerade das ist halt
auch nicht schlimm dass ich den ton
jetzt halten ich hab zum zocken ihren
halt nach herne auf dem video das halt
schon cool aber wenn ich ein spielzeug
wo der ton wichtig ist dass ich bald mal
machen möchte dann ist halt blöd weil
dann habe ich den noch nicht direkt ich
habe schon probiert kopfhörer
reinzustecken aber dann hab ich den ton
ich beim pc und wenn ich das das
also ich würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr
mir da in den kommentaren bisschen
weiterhelfen würde ich zeige euch jetzt
erst mal schnell was das für ein spiel
ist
ich bin ein hinter und ich muss das
gedrückthalten und wenn möglich auf die
nächste plattform kommen das heißt ich
muss jetzt auf die plattform von dem
vogel
wow träger der ist ganz schön weit
gesprochen werde jetzt ich mache jetzt
eben schnell neuen highscore
das ist doch nicht war als ob wir da
nicht direkt einfach das kann doch nicht
so schwer sein und das ist denn dieses
niveau habe kann ich da nicht wie
draufklicken stinktier von easy und man
komme jetzt ihr sorry sie diese
millimeter entscheidungen das kann doch
nicht sein
ich springe einfach hoch habe ich dann 4
kann es sein weil ich zwar auf einmal
gemacht aber dann mach ich jetzt noch
mal auf einmal alter was ist denn wenn
ich noch mal durch drücke ich glaube gar
nicht so lauten zwei uhr an einem
mittwoch so you try doch da war die 1 da
mal die zwei jedoch locker wenn das ich
habe heute morgen noch vor der uni meine
nachbarin vom fahrstuhl gesehen und die
sei noch nie so böse ausgehen könnte er
wahrscheinlich an das video von gestern
nahmen diesen komischen mit dem mit dem
wunsch das spiel leicht bringen nicht
jetzt spielt bringen den jo nicht fall
ninja das kann doch nicht so ich gucke
mir gerne immer so potentielle
gegenständen die ich durch zimmer werfen
können das muss doch nicht so schwer
sein
hu war ganz knapp
jedenfalls um die geschichte zu
verändern ich habe heute morgen meine
nachbarin vom fahrstuhl gesehen und ich
will nicht mit der zusammen falsche wer
an karneval war das halt nicht so cool
als wir mit der zusammen im fahrstuhl
gar nicht mit meinen freunden und mit
ihr und sie ist halt schon ein bisschen
älter und dann ist sie mal so ein
bisschen grimmig und heute morgen weil
sie besonders cremig zu guten morgen ich
so fahren sie runter ja so fahren sie
schauen wir haben hier noch was
vergessen wird direkt auf das war als
ich dann auf den tisch geschlagen hat
ist einfach beim einem drucker so
richtig sonne staub wieder hochkommt
musste echt mal putzen kann ja nicht so
schwer sind läuft eigentlich die
aufnahme
das kann bei der canon also wenn ihr
irgendwas ist mit dieser dass ich
irgendwie den den mit der synchronität
ist nicht mehr egal ich sagte er auf dem
ipad aber ich habe hier auf dem ipad
kein ton
ich hab den ton nur auf dem pc ich
möchte den ton auch aus dem ipad in und
aus dem pc
das ist so eine wunschvorstellung oder
kennt irgendwelche anderen programme
außer reflexe oder ärgert oder witzig
oder bleib ich mache jetzt eben schnell
ich kann mir das einfach richtig
vorstellen wie meine ich meine nachbarin
gerade ihn bei sich auf der die sie bei
sich auf der couch liegt oder als
cannabis la parra na ja das wird wohl
lieber sicher gerade irgendwie auf der
couch liegt und versucht einzupendeln
heute die von nebenan immer noch sein
ich bin ruhig ich bin ruhig ich bin ich
ich bin ruhig ich bin ruhig freunde
machen wir gerade nagellack auf meinen
mittelfinger ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt
was bringt ich weiß zwar nicht was das
bringen sollte aber damit hüpfe ich halt
immer das ist richtig kalkutta
roger haye ist das normal dass das so
ätzt alter das kann doch gar nicht sein
das darf doch nicht auf der haut ätzend
sonnen hey das ist ja auch richtig das
ist richtig kalt und es juckt ein ich
muss meinen es war halt noch gar keinen
sex mache aber ich finde einfach
schweben oder sonst käme es jetzt
eigentlich alles abgewaschen allen
moment ich mache mir jetzt die eben mal
schauen ob mir das bringen was gebracht
hat
ich bin plötzlich wieso ich in letzter
zeit immer ein bisschen gereizt bin
wahrscheinlich liegt einfach daran dass
ich derzeit halt diese uni klausurphase
halt wieder habe aber letztendlich gibt
es mir vielleicht auch ein bisschen
kraft dass ich jetzt endlich mal hier
einen neuen highscore packe und das
sieht ja schon mal mega gut aus ihr
denkt euch jetzt bestimmt wieder
das ist einfach das spiel schafft mal
mehr als acht alter
ich mache meine taktik bombe hat
geklappt okay wenn ich die nächsten auch
jetzt noch mal habe ich doch wieder ab
[Musik]
als ob das kaputt ist alles gerade hier
so ein bisschen kaputt gegangen glaube
ich dass ich auch einen gewissen haben
kommt für dich die das mikrofon eine
runde hier geht noch hier hoch sein
ich bin raus ich ein letzter rang 1
letzter 1
das ist doch jetzt da muss doch jetzt
hier mal gibt unterstützung freunde 7o
ist dass das ist doch nicht ab